well they can be pretty annoying and you
may get them maybe on a weekly even a
daily basis
telemarketing spam those robocalls why
do we get so many and what can we do
about it
the i-team's vanessa murphy looked into
it and is in our newsroom tonight with
more vanessa
denise you may notice many of these
calls are from the same area code as
your
phone number so you pick up thinking
it's your doctor's office your kid's
school
something important only to learn it's
not
please press one now to get connected
with certified technician
hey this is john i'm sorry if i missed
you i just wanted to reach out
personally
from those pesky robo calls to
telemarketing calls
all of a sudden recently i got six in
one day
marlo fuller says he's had enough you're
trying to do stuff and
the phone's constantly bothering you the
federal trade commission reports that
more than
46 thousand nevadans filed complaints
about robo calls in
twenty the state has the sixth highest
number of complaints in the nation
per capita about thirty five thousand
reported typical robo calls meaning
a human wasn't on the line more than
nine thousand reported live
callers hello your car warranty is about
to expire
the majority of calls are reported as
imposters
think fraudsters hello this is the irs
please contact us immediately as you are
being audited
warranties and protection plans are next
on the list
followed by offers to reduce debt we
don't want nevada residents
to be annoyed or scammed by these calls
the attorney general's office has a
consumer protection division
michelle newman is a senior deputy
attorney general
anything that would be considered a
deceptive trade practice that's
misleading
um that that's fraudulent that
omits any material information that
consumes consumers would
need to know in january nevada was part
of a federal lawsuit to take action
against a charity fraud tele-funding
operation
the lawsuit states eight defendants
reached 67 million consumers
and collected donations for practically
nonexistent
charitable programs including for
children's
cancer homeless veterans and fire
victims
according to the attorney general's
office the operation
stole about 110 million dollars from
donors
including nevadans while pocketing as
much as
90 cents for every dollar court records
reveal the defendants are now banned
from
fundraising and telemarketing and their
order to sell property
and donate to charity newman's advice
for consumers
just hang up don't dial any numbers
including an option to remove yourself
from the calling list
and register your number on the do not
call registry
as of 2020 the ftc reports more than 2
million
phone numbers in nevada are actively
registered on the do not call list
the problem scammers ignore it i'm on
the do not call list but i still get
these calls about my car warranty and
trying to sell me something
is that allowed no it's not allowed
you can report that unwanted call
as for fuller he has a long list of
phone numbers
he even did some digging and tracked
down one business address to an
empty lot i think
it should be shut down you know
especially if it is a scam
there are apps which can help block the
calls and there's usually also an
option on your cell phone to block the
calls now important to note the do not
call registry
doesn't prevent calls from political
groups debt collectors and surveys also
people can call you asking for
charitable donations and that's tricky
since that scam that was busted
earlier this year well they were asking
for charitable donations so you have to
make sure
you verify all the information